if you recall I gave you a bit of
introduction to this right what we did
was we had that idea of continuation do
you remember what I was talking about
when I said the word continuation what
was it trying to get out yeah very busy
so many I didn't ask they start with one
idea one definition and then you're like
oh um what if we want to go outside that
definition so one be example I gave with
this I said you start with a definition
of it and you know what is this from
systems respond this way and on one but
that definition somewhat contradicts
that which turned out to be really
important for us in binomial theorem a
zero factorial come nah man
reckon a lot right so if we can keep
that definition we extended it there are
other things you could do by the way for
example we extend this to 0
but we didn't expense to say for example
what's this right like how you defined
that or what about you know three and a
quarter
or how about what about this one that or
what was that read right now there are
ways to extend then continue the
factorial function anyway but we said
the tree you need to calculate is not
happiness it has a continued on foot the
tree we said we're going to start with
the right angle triangle a right angle
triangle and then we're going to
continue the definition outside other
two tables what was the tool that we do
to do that
which is the unit circle fantastic we're
going to return to being a circle today
what I thought we might do is all this
time we'd like the looking basic method
I'm going to show you Freeman I have
salted one of those basil in circles
once they were wrapping one up and forth
and then to find a way it actually the
most common but I think doubly useful in
the long run but it's easier to learn on
the go for that so here's the question
sine theta equals a hop and they say
feet are have this restriction on this
domain restriction now they have to put
this restriction in because if you get
your calculator out right now just going
to ditch ocean I know definitely weird
and I'll actually tell you right from
the get-go what's the answers her feet
are ah but then imma show you again how
to get there it won't pop but this is
what I want you to know I'll slide the
you to the heart make sure you
calculated in degrees notice issued
mentor to someone else's life and if you
gather is sine of 30 degrees okay it
should basically return to you a hot
okay what that means is 30 degrees is a
solution for theta I can put it in in
satisfies degree
what's the only wonder if you go ahead
and you change 30 to 150 again you get a
hook could be R equals 150 degrees in a
novice position
but I'll keep going change 150 it's time
foot in 390 and if you can equals it
says up and then if you take five oh I'm
thinking 500 then if you put inside 500
intent
it says aha and we can keep playing this
game for red ones in fact there is an
infinite number solutions to this quiz
okay you know when you check you in
equation like this there is one solution
and only one right if I dare you an
equation like this there are two
equations if I gave your 2d it might be
true quick sorry it's not equation
solution
it might be three solution but when you
have a ravine gun right you're getting
four number solution and that's why they
say archaically something this is
looking a little narrow band let's just
look at the tradition and should find it
and zero to 360 degrees is the most
common restriction it needs the way I'm
going to go about it I'm going to say
first lady she used my first step find
the base table now what does that mean
and it means find the first solution to
this differential equation
ah yes sometimes Vicki angle but under
color of a single for reasons that will
become clear in a couple elections an
acute angle is not always the best
you'll see one okay after the base angle
is kind of like the first solution I can
find of which I can build all the rest
of those solutions in Ohio G 3150 when I
think 39510 what I'm doing is I know
what are they saying Elizabeth and I can
I learn how to build the resolution dr.
and I will show you how to do so what do
you get the variable if you ignore the
size
yeah I heard this is a bit sort of
revision commodity there's no science of
my money supply right very tackle it off
and you say shift sign of the number
yeah so you can go ahead you can put
that in shift by 0.55 and it shouldn't
have actually thirty degrees is that ok
so what we've done is I'm going to say
the state table is what I put into my
calculator at least in by the way even
though it's exactly how you would read
it please don't say that signs of the
mud what I'll greet that as sine inverse
or inverse science if you want to be
really ready go to our slides but we're
not in your restaurant already to that
site in my solve this thing River on the
right hand side column you your
equipment kitchen on there to be
cautious with that we're going to learn
later on this is a dangerous object you
have to great pepper with it so you
can't write it but you'll see later on
while I talk about one danger simply
whatever you want okay so this guy down
here I want you to know if you're beside
right so if the regatta lie had up here
sine theta equals negative 1/2 I would
still put this supplies up I think I'm
just going to write it and you should as
well because like and then that dark
hand back to you
how do you